whether you're new to the division or a
seasoned player coming over from the
original the division to has a number of
new concepts that can seem quite
overwhelming when you first get deployed
into Washington DC although this video
is more directed towards new players you
might find a few tips here that will
help you on your way to getting back
control of the US Capitol there are
already a number of amazing and very
detailed guides out in the community but
sometimes these can be a little scary
for players only just starting out here
a a tip to simplify things a bit while
still giving you the information you
need in a concise and easy to understand
format similar to the beginners guide
series around the division 1 the series
will start at the point of when you
first stepped foot into Washington DC
will then move on to some of the more
complicated builds and activities as we
progress through the game
[Music]
[Music]
you
upon arriving in Washington DC your
first job is to locate and fight your
way into the White House this will
become your base of operations for the
rest of the game the base of operations
is your main hub you were spending a lot
of time here between missions and other
activities in this area you'll have
access to things like vendors the
crafting table recalibration station as
well as the clan quarters in the PvP
area I'll go into more detail on these
later on when you first visit the White
House most of these won't be available
straight away you need to upgrade your
White House in order to unlock most of
these in order to unlock them you just
need to play through the main storyline
and over time these will become
available and the majority of these are
from the settlements settlements or
areas with civilians of group together
walled off an area and are attempting to
rebuild these are basically like a mini
base of operations your job as a
division agent is to help these
settlements rebuild after performing a
number of tasks a member of the
settlement will agree to come on board
and work at the White House unlocking a
new vendor skills and perks are an
important part of the division and these
can be found at the quartermaster this
vendor is available as soon as you walk
into the White House initially you don't
have any skills or perks the first poke
you get is the ability to equip the
second weapon but later on you can keep
upgrading to hold more meat cuts and
grenades or unlocked certain blueprints
I'll cover the skills in more detail on
later video but for one of your first
skills it's not a bad idea to use a
skill that can help you heal while in
combat like the restorer hive for your
second skill it's completely up to you
but something like the assault turret
can be quite useful when you're first
starting out but don't feel it is stuck
with whatever skill you choose over time
you'll be able to unlock them all new
skills and perks can be unlocked through
the quartermaster using shd tech this is
the first currency that you'll need to
find shd takers feel easy to find though
a lot of it will be gained through
running through the main storyline as
all main missions reward upon completion
but also can be found out in the open
world often behind padlocked cages
[Music]
leveling up your character will open up
stronger gear and greater abilities in
the early game the missions are the main
way of progressing completing these will
earn you the greatest rewards relative
to your level on the map they look like
this the only thing that you need to be
aware of is a level associated with them
this is the level of the enemy if your
character level is under this you'll
have a hard time so to level up your
character there's a number of other
activities you can do the open world has
a huge number of activities from rich
cooing hostages to capturing control
points around the map as you progress
through the game these activities will
get harder offering greater rewards and
experience to start with a lot of these
will be marked on the map with a
question mark but as you get closer the
event will reveal itself these instances
are quite short and usually have a few
waves of enemies and something that you
need to protect or gain control of when
it comes to the control points it's
about taking over an area of the map for
the civilians in the local district when
approaching the enemy control point you
can send up a flare which will bring a
number of people to assist you in
declaring the enemies all of the
open-world activities will reward you
with experience credits and usually gear
and all crafting blueprints the control
points are particularly lucrative and
can offer you a bunch of gear once
they've been captured and also some way
that you can fast travel to making it
easier to move around the map projects
are tasks that are given to us from the
settlements safe houses and there are
also daily and weekly projects that are
constantly being updated
most of these are completed by playing
the game as per usual but some are too
clicked shd take in the open world which
will help with unlocking your skills and
perks and donating gear that you pick up
over time you'll collect a lot of gear
and weapons that will quickly become
obsolete as you level up but before you
sell or dismantle these to make space in
your bag check your projects the easiest
way to check these is to go into your
map screen and click on this icon here
scrolling through the projects you'll
see this donation button down the bottom
if it lights up there's something in
your inventory that can be donated to
the project projects or would experience
credits and gear sight missions are
basically just smaller main missions
most of these will just pop up on the
map as you progress through the story
but some are hidden and require you to
talk to someone before they become
available upon completion the side
missions reward you with experience
credits and a blueprint but I wouldn't
suggest doing the side missions early on
as you start moving towards level 30
leveling up becomes harder and more
experience is required the experience
that side missions provide scales with
your current level and always seems to
give around 1/3 of your current level
width of XP so leaving these until you
around level 18 or higher will provide
greater benefits towards your climb to
level 30 we only going to briefly cover
the section because this is just a video
on level 1 to 30 and over this time gear
and weapons you pickup will very quickly
become redundant as higher level items
drop and this will continue to happen
until you make it to the in-game of will
tear 5 for now I just recommend trying
everything out especially the weapons
get a feel for them
test them all out they all have their
own pros and cons they all handle
differently some are semi-auto some auto
but there are some things that don't
change like the optimal range of each
with an archetype all of the weapons
have a number of talents associated with
them gaining a number is the rarity of
the items increase but don't worry too
much about these just yet as I said once
you start gaining a couple levels
regardless of what's on it and what
rarity it is you'll be needing to change
it out for a higher level piece
I wanted to quickly cover this because
it certainly confused me all of these
random things I was picking up around
the streets while making your way
through the missions and roaming around
the open world you'll find a lot of
chests bags rubbish bins drums boxes etc
that can all be looted some will contain
gear and weapons others might have
materials you might even find things
like children's socks and measuring
tapes just collect everything when your
gear and weapons fill up donate
dismantle or sell it because most of its
probably stuff that you forgot about
that you're hoarding anyway with the
materials a lot of this will become
useful later on so just grab as much as
you can remember to keep an eye on your
projects some of them will ask you to
donate X amount of water or food to a
control point if you fill up you can
increase your holding space by some of
the perks in the quartermaster the
materials will become very useful later
on when you start using the crafting
table in recalibration station there's
certainly no reason why you couldn't
start crafting blueprints before level
30 but it definitely isn't necessary my
recommendation would be to hold back
unless you fill up with materials I'll
go into more depth on crafting and
blueprints and materials in a later
video
[Music]
the division-2 is a cover shooter this
means that when in combat you should be
utilizing obstacles and your
surroundings to hide and take cover from
enemy gunfire even when compared to the
original game the division to as far
more reliant on you taking cover if
there is one thing you take away from
this video this is it I had thousands of
hours spent in the division one and even
I wasn't fully prepared for health
valued and cover odds in the scam
picking the right place to take cover
can make all the difference in the
firefight rather than rushing in guns
a-blazing assists the situation first
quite often you can spot the enemy's
long before they spot you so before
engaging stand back take a look at the
cover points around you if you find a
piece of cover how easily can you be
flanked by the enemy do you have room to
move away from grenades where are all
the enemies what type of enemies are
they this may seem like a lot of
planning but you'll get faster this
you'll be able to assist an area in just
a couple of seconds but if you start
doing this I promise you'll have a lot
more success the last one can actually
quite important learn your enemies each
hostile faction has a different style of
combat and within each of these factions
they have different types of units for
example all of the factions will have
some kind of Russia that will haul ass
towards you regardless of what fire
you're laying down it's a good idea to
try and take out these guys first but
then you have the medics and engineers
and don't forget about those annoying
grenade dudes so you've managed to find
a sweet position to take on a group of
hyenas guarding an area and you
successfully take them down next you
here
these could come from anywhere including
right behind you the mini-map is
extremely valuable in this situation at
a glance you can quickly gauge where
they're coming from in fact in all
situations this should be the most often
looked at part of your screen think of
it like the rearview mirrors in your car
you should attempt to get into the habit
of chickens so often that you don't even
realize you're doing it the NPC's are
smarter in this game and if you're not
keeping an eye on your mini-map you're
likely getting flanked learn your skills
I don't mean study up on them I mean try
them all out your skills aren't going to
be overly powerful at this stage but if
you feel as though you're falling short
somewhere the right skill could change
the outcome of the fight for example you
could be a solo player and you may be
finding you're having a lot of trouble
getting flanked a well-placed assault
turret will not only predict you on one
side but will also draw a lot of enemy
fire maybe you're having trouble with
keeping heels and you keep running out
of armor kits there are a number of
skills that will help you heal your
other wife tip rather than leaving your
skills ran out on their own and manually
shut them down this can dramatically
shorten the cooldown towards the next
use thanks wifey the skill options are
huge and I'll actually doing another
guide on the soon but until then just
try them all out
[Music]
there's so much more detail that could
have gone into with each of these
categories but in the interests of
keeping it short and concise and not too
confusing for beginners I've cut a lot
out there are also a number of other
areas though it's going to talk about
but for now this is more than enough to
get you on your way to level 30
take your time running through the story
and enjoy the beautiful world that
they've created but if you were just
wanting to rush through it the concepts
are still the same
run missions until they level get too
high then focus on open world activities
and projects to rank up when you get to
around level 18 to 30 start reading side
missions alongside the main missions I
have a massive number of topics I'll be
talking about in future beginner guide
videos so keep an eye out for any of
your most seasoned players that have
watched through this video please leave
a comment with any tips you may have the
new players otherwise I'll wrap this one
up here and catch you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]